hey we'll stop time your leads here and
one of the things I love doing is
teaching people to swim I'm here at my
local golf club with my baby girl
teaching to the swim and this this
message that I'm about to give you is a
really important message because I see
some people in the property industry
know I kick in property and sometimes
they're chickens and they never go in
the water but then other times people in
the property industry that they're so
brave they have no fear which is gray
but they jump in and they buy deals off
deal sources and they go crazy and they
get really burned and something that I
thought today while with my little baby
girl you all right there Ruby Ruby you
want to go back in the pool the thing is
when I first started taking Ruby
swimming she would literally see the
water and she just below she'd just go
for it like like a fly to a lamp and he
used to really scare me because I
thought although I love the fact that
she likes water what happens if she sees
water when I'm not there and just jumps
in I know she'll drown and I'd be there
in the water table you're saying come on
Ruby come and jump in I'll catch her and
she just been running around you truly
jump in and I be sure I'll catch her and
constantly on guard and although I loved
the fearlessness of Ruby I worried for a
life sometimes so I decided to do is
whether I saw Ruby and I saw that she
was trying to jump in the water and
despite me not watching and telling it
to jump in and I let her I'll jump in
and I thought I'm not going to quickly
catch her I'm gonna let it go underwater
for just like split second so she can
experience the nose Russian and the
water goes in your nose and it's all
horrible I wanted to experience that and
Amanda said you know that's mean things
it's not mean I wanted her to know what
happens when you jump in without an
instructor without our mouths without
Daddy there because she needs to
understand water and after that point
that happened maybe three months ago
after that point now she loved the water
still but she has a healthy respect for
water she doesn't just jump in she'll
look she'll be cautious and she'll go in
and now she's learning to swim we've got
some armbands and I think in the
property industry it's exactly the same
I see some people they were chickens
don't go near the water don't go near
financial freedom don't go near property
deals because I think oh my gosh I've
heard stories of people
losing money and then they're just
chickens you want to be a chicken so
chicken you'll never get to experience
swimming you'll just have to be in a job
forever but there's some people we call
them motivated idiots they're the guys
it just go crazy jumping in with with no
training with no instructor with no
armbands and they don't understand they
don't respect the property business they
just the are do it'll be fine no it
won't be fine you've got to get the
right training you've got to get you got
to go them properly you got to be
careful you got to be mature so what's
my advice to you go in have no fear
but just make sure that you've got the
right instructors our people say oh
you're only saying this because you're
you've on property training programs no
no it's the other way around
I run property training programs because
I know the importance of it and any
ports of Education do it do it
cautiously take massive action but
always look at the best case in worst
case always have the right training and
with them with the support you can
better swim in this field and be super
successful anyway I'm gonna jump in the
hot tub and spend some more time with my
baby girl this is screaming you made you
go back in all right I'll see you next
time thanks so much subscribe like
comment thanks so much
come on baby